Lucia: 还是二楼的客厅要装饰
Lucia: Or should we also decorate the second-floor living room?
Lucia: 是只把一楼的客厅装饰完
Jake: 就一楼吧
Jake: Just the first floor.
Jake: 然后还有各位的房间
Jake: And then everyone's rooms.
Jake: 我可能找个时间
Jake: I'll find some time...
Jake: 今天或者明天或者等你们收拾好
Jake: Today or tomorrow or whenever you finish tidying up.
Jake: 总之就是
Jake: Anyway...
Jake: 这几天我会把整个房子用iPhone扫一遍
Jake: I'll scan the whole house with an iPhone in the next few days.
Jake: 嗯然后各位的卧室就收拾收拾
Jake: And then you guys can tidy up your bedrooms.
Jake: 对要扫进去
Jake: Yes, they need to be scanned.
Lucia: 那你要不扫之前通知一声
Lucia: How about you let us know before scanning?
Jake:对对当然当然
Lucia: 这样我就可以在扫之前
Lucia: So I can move that box before you scan.
Lucia: 把那个箱子拉起来
Lucia: Lift it up.
Jake:当然了当然了
Lucia: 薇薇
Lucia: Tasha?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha: 你困啦
Tasha: Are you sleepy?
Katrina:  我还不困
Katrina: I'm not sleepy yet.
Lucia: 我这没口袋这个东西
Lucia: I don't have a pocket for this.
Lucia: 要不然把它拔了
Lucia: How about I just unplug it?
Lucia: 哈哈呃
Lucia: Haha, uh...
Jake: 你看一下它有多少电
Jake: Check how much battery it has.
Jake: 如果电很多的话没关系
Jake: If it has a lot, it's fine.
Lucia: 哦我在手机上能看
Lucia: Oh, I can see it on my phone.
Lucia: 到它有多少电
Lucia: How much battery it has.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice: 又找到他在这
Alice: Found him here again.
Lucia: 93%是不是应该可以拔
Lucia: 93%, should be enough to unplug, right?
Jake: 可以OK
Jake: Yeah, that's fine.
Jake: 对你坐着的时候充嘛
Jake: Just charge it while sitting.
Jake: 然后站着就
Jake: And then while standing...
Tasha: 就还剩这些最后这
Tasha: So, there's only these left.
Tasha: 最后一二三四五六六块没有
Tasha: The last one, two, three, four, five, six pieces haven't found a home yet.
Tasha: 找着家了
Tasha: Found their spots.
Alice: 看看像不像
Alice: See if they look similar.
Tasha: 嗯像
Tasha: Hmm, they do.
Tasha: 但不一定他们俩在一起感觉
Tasha: But not necessarily together, it feels like.
Tasha: 这个在这边
Tasha: This one goes here.
Lucia: 他怎么突然变成network error了
Jake: 啊我看一下
Jake: Ah, let me take a look.
Jake: 可以给我看一下吗
Jake: Can you show me?
Lucia: 对就是在我把电拔掉之后
Lucia: Yeah, it happened after I unplugged it.
Lucia: 他突然变成这个界面了
Lucia: It suddenly turned to this screen.
Lucia: 这个是什么意思
Lucia: What does this mean?
Shure:  你先把这几个这个对齐
Jake: 重开一下
Jake: Restart it.
Jake:我也没见过这个
Jake: I've never seen this before.
Lucia: 就我把它这样
Lucia: So, I did this.
Lucia: 就是这样关掉重开一下什么情况
Lucia: Just turn it off and on again, what's going on?
Shure:  先先先来这个先先把一根给一边
Shure: First, first, first give one side to...
Shure:  给那什么
Shure: To whatever.
Jake: 好我这出不来
Jake: Okay, I can't get this out.
Shure:  你把那缩一下
Shure: Shrink that part.
Tasha: 这样这个猪就塞不下他
Tasha: Like this, the pig won't fit.
Jake: 这个长度是对的吗
Jake: Is this the right length?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Katrina:  都一样的
Katrina: They're all the same.
Shure:  都是一样
Shure: They're all the same.
Katrina:  对一下
Katrina: Check it.
Lucia: 啊出来了他应该还是正常的吧
Lucia: Ah, it's back to normal, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yep.
Lucia: 可能是刚才有什么bug了
Lucia: Maybe there was a bug earlier.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 螺母呢
Shure: 这样角度给他推上去
Jake: 或者装饰二楼
Jake: Or decorate the second floor.
Jake: 因为二楼的那个场地
Jake: Because the space on the second floor...
Jake: 就做PPT比较方便
Jake: It's more convenient for making PPTs.
Jake: 就是就可以摆那个
Jake: You can set up...
Jake: 摆摆椅子
Jake: Set up chairs.
Jake: 摆很多椅子
Jake: Set up lots of chairs.
Lucia: 哦对对
Lucia: Oh, right, right.
Lucia: 因为二楼的桌子椅子太像那个椅子了
Lucia: Because the tables and chairs on the second floor look too much like those chairs.
Tasha: 太像那边了
Tasha: They look too similar to over there.
Jake: 对所以在二楼装饰
Jake: Yeah, so we decorated the second floor.
Shure:  完了是不是要脑血栓了
Alice: 哈哈但我觉得他俩又不像一家
Alice: Haha, but I don't think they look like a family.
Alice: 因为这个角不太好拼
Alice: Because this corner is hard to piece together.
Alice: 就比较尖的角
Alice: It's a rather sharp corner.
Alice: 有没有比较尖的角
Alice: Are there any sharp corners?
Tasha: 他的嘴是吗
Tasha: His mouth, right?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Jake: 剩了一圈了
Jake: There's a loop left.
Jake: 这一圈很强
Jake: This loop is really strong.
Lucia: 但是感觉只有
Lucia: But it feels like only
Shure:  再再拿一副
Lucia: 只有这几个是比较确定的
Lucia: Only these few are more certain.
Lucia: 我们找到了很多两个
Lucia: We found a lot of pairs.
Lucia: 两个是一起的
Lucia: Two are together.
Tasha: 找到了好朋友
Tasha: Found some good friends.
Lucia: 但是确定了放在哪里
Lucia: But we're sure where to put them.
Tasha: 但是找不到他们的家
Tasha: But can't find their home.
Jake: 好多好朋友
Jake: Lots of good friends.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun.
Lucia: 哇哎这个真的好一致啊
Lucia: Wow, this is really consistent.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Lucia: 这个你是怎么找到的
Lucia: How did you find this?
Tasha: 这两个尖尖
Tasha: These two pointy parts.
Jake: 我去这尖尖你能看到
Jake: Oh my, you can see those pointy parts?
Jake: 眼神真好
Jake: Great eyesight.
Jake: 我这看不清
Jake: I can't see clearly.
Tasha: 哦这个弧度我之前看到过
Tasha: Oh, I've seen this curve before.
Jake: 有点6
Jake: Pretty awesome.
Shure:  人生的最后7天
Shure: The last 7 days of life.
Shure:  来吧立起来
Shure: Come on, stand it up.
Lucia: 会不会是那个鸟翅膀
Lucia: Could it be that bird's wing?
Shure:  哦还有一个是吗
Shure: Oh, there's another one, right?
Shure:  对还有一个
Shure: Yes, there's another one.
Shure:  先把这根给弄上
Lucia: 哎棒棒
Lucia: Oh, awesome
Tasha: 棒棒
Tasha: Awesome
Tasha: 那说明鸟不在边边
Tasha: That means the bird isn't on the edge
Lucia: 诶这个
Lucia: Hey, this
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right
Lucia: 这个这个
Lucia: This one, this one
Shure:  聪明到爆了好吗
Lucia: 感觉这个弧度很像
Lucia: Feels like this curve matches
Shure:  OK
Lucia: 很像哎
Lucia: It really looks like it
Jake: 确实有点像
Jake: It does look a bit like it
Lucia: 哎对
Lucia: Oh yeah
Lucia: 这个也是对的
Lucia: This one is correct too
Jake: 这是你记住的吗
Jake: Is this what you remembered?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: Then
Shure:  OK
Tasha: 再
Tasha: Again
Lucia: 这儿进去吗
Lucia: Does it go in here?
Alice: 像又不太像这个头
Alice: It looks like it, but the head doesn't quite match
Lucia: 诶我们刚才是不是给这个蛇
Lucia: Hey, did we just find a friend for this snake?
Lucia: 已经找到了一个小伙伴
Lucia: We've already found a buddy for the snake
Tasha: 对蛇跟那个熊猫哎
Tasha: Yes, the snake and the panda
Tasha: 怎么怎么怎么弄来着
Tasha: How did we do it again?
Lucia: 啊对对对
Lucia: Oh right, right, right
Alice: 有人长这样吗
Alice: Does anyone look like this?
Lucia: 好像不太有人长这样
Lucia: It doesn't seem like anyone looks like this
Shure: 无敌
Lucia: 嗯好像也不是呢
Lucia: Hmm, seems like it's not either
Jake: 把它弄一边长是吧
Jake: Make it longer on one side, right?
Jake:那把它竖过来倒过来
Jake: Then make it vertical and flip it over
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes
Tasha: 就还剩最后的
Tasha: Only the last one left
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes
Tasha: 这这两个也没找着家是吗
Tasha: These two haven't found a home yet, right?
Tasha: 还剩最后5个没找着家的
Tasha: There are still five left without a home
Tasha: 要不尝试着把它们把这些放进去吧
Tasha: Why don't we try putting these in and see what shape comes out?
Tasha: 说不定形状就出来了
Tasha: Maybe the shape will just appear
Shure:  都行其实嗯
Shure: Anything works actually, yeah
Shure:  也别太长
Shure: Don't make it too long
Shure:  别比那个黑板
Shure: Don't make it longer than the blackboard
Lucia: 这怎么放能让他不不位移
Lucia: How do we place it so it doesn't shift?
Jake:这样呗
Jake: Like this.
Shure:  差不多
Shure:  这个还是高嗯
Shure: This is still high, hmm.
Jake: 这个高一点
Jake: This one is a bit higher.
Shure:  再高一点点这个
Shure: Raise it a bit more.
Shure:  啊过了
Shure: Ah, too much.
Shure:  过了过了
Shure: Too much, too much.
Shure:  OK OK差不多
Shure:  yes
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  把它拼上对
Shure: Put it together, right.
Shure:  yes
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  yes perfect
Alice: 这俩像在一块吗
Alice: Do these two look like they're together?
Shure:  人类的智慧
Shure: Human wisdom.
Tasha: 像又不太像
Tasha: They look alike but not quite.
Lucia: 这个好像
Lucia: This one does.
Lucia: 是不是很像在一起啊
Lucia: Don't they look very similar?
Lucia: 这俩
Lucia: These two.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 然后这个如果还在这的话就是这样
Lucia: And if this one is here, then it's like this.
Shure:  师傅你是干什么工作的
Shure: Master, what do you do for work?
Jake: 修空调的
Jake: I repair air conditioners.
Lucia: 接下来这里还缺一个
Lucia: Next, there's still one missing here.
Shure:  先头先头按上去
Shure: Put the first one on first.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 这个怎么看起来很短
Jake: Why does this one look so short?
Lucia: 是谁呢
Lucia: Who is it?
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  OK的OK
Shure: It's OK, it's OK.
Tasha: 我们已经越来越接近真相了
Tasha: We're getting closer to the truth.
Jake:我可以的
Jake: I can do it.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 越来越有拼下去的动力了
Tasha: We are more motivated to keep going.
Tasha: 还有3个人无家可归哎不是他
Tasha: There are still three people without a home. Oh, not him.
Shure: 这有个螺母
Shure: 给他固定上
Tasha: 这个感觉这个小家伙在哪都行
Tasha: This little guy seems to fit anywhere.
Shure:  啊不你要给他下边它是一个六边形的
Shure:  嗯你要找好那个
Shure: Hmm, you need to find the right spot.
Shure: 那个角度
Jake: 卡死了
Shure: 对卡死了你先把那个螺母推进去
Shure:  然后上面就可以，进行下一步
Lucia: 这个猫好像不在这里
Lucia: This cat doesn't seem to be here.
Jake: 但是你可以把右边形给找着
Jake: But you can find the shape on the right.
Shure: 哎呀
Lucia: 吓我一跳
Lucia: You scared me!
Shure: 完了你给你给人家
Shure:  给人饭碗端了
Lucia: 那好像又不是真想要完全放进去
Lucia: But it seems like it's not really meant to be fully inserted.
Tasha: 可是就是会有点边角的
Tasha: But there will be some edges.
Shure: 烘焙材料
Katrina: 甜品
Lucia: 哎是是是
Lucia: Oh, yes, yes, yes.
Tasha: 嘿嘿嘿
Tasha: Hehehe.
Alice: 我感觉这个不对了
Alice: I feel this is wrong.
Lucia: 这个地方塞进去了
Lucia: This part is inserted.
Lucia: 不对那这个肯定在这
Lucia: No, this definitely goes here.
Lucia: 这个怎么看都有点像那个猫猫
Tasha: 可能不清
Tasha: Maybe it's not clear.
Alice:这个头吗
Alice: This head?
Katrina:  这给我看刚刚这个
Katrina: Show me that just now.
Katrina:  刚刚这个是归谁吗
Katrina: Whose was this just now?
Jake:缺吗
Shure: 缺一个最后一个
Tasha: 这个不归谁
Tasha: This doesn't belong to anyone.
Katrina: 啊行
Katrina: Ah, okay.
Shure: one last
Shure: 完了
Shure: It's over.
Alice: 哎啊对啊
Alice: Oh, yes, yes.
Tasha: 啊对对对，他们仨是归着的
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, yeah, they belong together.
Katrina:  然后这还有一组这还有一组
Katrina: And then there's another set, and another set here.
Jake:这根是干吗的啊
Alice: 这个这个有归家吗
Alice: Does this one belong to a family?
Lucia: 斯他刚才咱是不是他和熊猫也是女生
Lucia: He just... wasn't he and the panda also girls?
Shure: 这个
Shure:  他是夹黑板的
Lucia: 不是他是蛇是蛇
Lucia: No, he's a snake, a snake.
Lucia: 那这个豹子
Lucia: Then this leopard.
Shure: 他俩应该不是不穿一起
Shure: They shouldn't be placed together.
Lucia: 这豹子这个平平的面很好找呀
Lucia: This leopard, it's easy to find the flat side.
Shure: 看图
Katrina:  这里哦这里有六边形
Katrina: Here, oh, there's a hexagon here.
Jake:这两边是吗
Jake: 不对
Jake: No.
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Katrina: 这俩人
Katrina: These two people.
Katrina:  干啥
Katrina: What are they doing?
Alice:这里这样子的
Alice: It's like this here.
Shure: 搞定
Tasha: 那这还直
Tasha: Then this is straight.
Tasha: 这正好还差一个边
Tasha: This just misses one side.
Alice: 对你说的那个平平的是不是这个
Alice: Yes, the flat part you mentioned, is it this one?
Jake:那那个应该是卡在这的
Jake:看起来是吗
Jake:卡在这不道啊
Lucia: 他们他们有点
Lucia: They, they are a bit
Jake:应该怎么卡
Lucia: 有点像边
Lucia: A bit like
Shure: 我想想看
Shure: Let me think
Shure: 你把这个卡扣松开
Jake:比划比划要不
Shure: 我想想
Tasha: 刚刚找了半天
Tasha: Just spent a long time looking
Jake:应该这样
Jake:过不去
Jake:它得这么放
Jake:是不是这么卡的
Jake:这个是
Lucia: 这现在这些个编的顺序我们拼的
Lucia: The current order of these edits that we've put together
Shure: good question
Lucia: 不一定是
Lucia: Might not be
Shure: 比划比划
Shure: 是我在想他是怎么卡
Shure: 躺下来底下也得有个接着它的地方
Jake: 这个不用卡吗这个
Lucia: 也有一点
Lucia: Also a little bit
Lucia: 放进去试试
Lucia: Try putting it in
Alice: 哎对
Alice: Yeah, right
Lucia: 那这里需要卡吗
Lucia: Do we need to wedge it here
Shure: 这个是卡哪的这个是卡这的
Jake: 智慧
Jake: Wisdom
Tasha: 放哪了
Tasha: Where did you put it
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 我刚刚哦这样接近真相了啊这
Lucia: I just, oh, we're getting close to the truth now, ah this
Shure:  am i 牛逼
Shure:  牛逼
Shure: Awesome
Shure:  确实牛逼
Shure:  上面那个给它给它弄一下
Katrina:  像像挨着这个的
Katrina: Like, like next to this one
Shure:  那把这个加低一点
Lucia: 挨着这里挨着这里
Lucia: Next to here, next to here
Lucia: 呃，推一下这里
Lucia: Uh, push here
Jake:往下吧往下往下
Alice:他俩拼到了
Alice: They matched it
Lucia: 他俩拼到了
Lucia: They matched it
Lucia: 哎呀，刚刚那个呢
Lucia: Oh no, what about that one
Tasha: 好好好真相只有一个
Tasha: Okay okay okay, there's only one truth
Lucia: 啊，我，我
Lucia: Ah, I, I
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright
Jake:哎这往上往下
Shure: 往下
Jake: 下不来
Shure: 能
Lucia: 这好像还挺像的
Lucia: This looks quite similar
Lucia: 有可能是动
Lucia: It could be moving
Shure:  太牛了我们
Shure: We're so awesome
Lucia: 接下来的这一边
Lucia: Next to this side
Shure: 拼好了黑板可还行
Jake: 确实有黑板背面就是黑板
Jake: 他俩是一
Jake: They are one
Shure:  这这不是
Shure:  对
Jake: 放哪了
Shure: 太牛了
Shure:  可以
Lucia: 就这一块规则它应该在中间的
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia:然后这个是在
Lucia: And this one is in...
Lucia:那这个应该在上面
Shure:  困了
Jake:几点睡的啊
Tasha: 1点 对
Tasha: 1 o'clock. Yeah.
Shure: 1点多
Jake: 几点醒的
Katrina:  10点
Jake:那够了
Tasha: 只有这个边和这个边位
Tasha: Only this side and this side are like this.
Tasha: 人类是这样的
Tasha: Humans are like this.
Shure:  我1点半睡的然后七点醒
Shure:  你
Katrina:  你五点半才睡
Shure:  整两杯咖啡吧不然的话受不了了
Jake:走我们一起整两杯
Jake:上楼
Shure: 没有只有瓜儿
Lucia: 嗯看看
Lucia: Hmm, let's see.
Jake: 下午会有人带我们去做
Jake: Someone will take us to do it in the afternoon.
Katrina:  我没看到
Katrina: I didn't see it.
Shure:  旁边楼上比我们好像热一点
Katrina:  楼上不通风
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:那怎么通
Jake: How to ventilate then?
Jake: 人书这东西
Jake: People, books, these things...
Shure: 是的这谁的布洛芬你的
Katrina:  姐姐会来吗
Katrina: Will my sister come?
Katrina:  哎等等什什么谁是一家来着
Katrina: Wait, wait, what, who are a family again?
Katrina:  对对他那个短头发
Katrina: Yes, yes, the one with short hair.
Jake: 他在鹰翅膀的某一个地方
Jake: He's in some place with eagle wings.
Katrina:  他们要实验室上班是吧
Katrina: They work in the lab, right?
Jake: 打完卡就可以了  Lucia: 对的对的
Jake: Just clock in and it's done. Lucia: Yes, yes.
Jake: 然后他也不一样
Katrina:  他们昨天晚上那么晚走
Shure:  12点大左右
Shure: Around 12 o'clock.
Jake: 夜生活刚开始吧
Jake: 如果没有这些事的话
Katrina:  他开车的应该还好是吧
Katrina: He should be fine while driving, right?
Jake: 我们如果布置二楼的话
Shure:  什么
Jake:我们如果布置这个二楼
Jake: 因为我们活动场地有可能在这
Shure:  哎我们随手拿的咖啡放哪里来着
Shure:  在这呢
Shure:  昨天谁把这冰箱给拔了
Shure: 不知道谁干的
Shure: 镇的酒都不凉了
Shure: 卧槽
Tasha: 你要最量
Tasha: You want the most.
Shure: 咱们纸抽在哪
Jake: 呃这边
Jake: 怎么了
Shure:  摆摆桌子两个让我找纸找不到
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Lucia: 哎呀幸好外面有一层
Jake:对
Alice:电子秤
Tasha: 还有个袋子吗
Jake:这边有很多
Jake:是这个吗
Tasha: 呃这些对吧
Jake: 烤箱在哪
Tasha: 那呢
Jake: 那我放哪呢
Tasha: 削皮刀哪
Shure: 哪有烤箱
Tasha: 我觉得应该放烤箱上面
Tasha: 微波炉上面比较合适
Shure: 咱是不只有微波炉
Jake: 你买烤箱了
Jake: You bought an oven?
Tasha: 温度计烤箱温度计
Shure: 买烤箱了吗
Katrina:  好专业啊
Alice:啊这提拉米苏那个叉
Alice: 对对对提拉米苏的叉
Alice: Yeah, yeah, the tiramisu fork.
Tasha: 还有提拉米苏的盒子
Tasha: 嗯这伯爵红茶包
Jake: 这些东西昨天应该都扫一遍
Jake: 扫一天
Tasha: 可可粉
Tasha: 这个是那个咖啡酒.
Jake:就是帮忙换个
Katrina: 你会调酒吗
Shure:  我啊
Jake: 看起来会一点
Jake: Looks like you know a bit.
Shure: 可以会可以会我
Lucia: 最简单的是买几瓶可乐然后对一块就完事了
Shure:  有上面6个下面6个12个
Shure: 我靠这什么
Jake:架上去吧
Shure:  咱们经费这么充足么 我感觉我是不应该花花呀
Shure:  哈哈
Katrina: 咱都是他的助手
Jake:这边主要花了
Katrina: 买点柠檬片
Jake:非常有用
Katrina:  我来记一下
Katrina: I'll write it down.
Tasha: 啊对我也要买柠檬
Jake: 嗯对下午要买东西就记一下菜单吧
Jake: 或者单写在那个白板上面
Jake:这个白板你们现在都可以写吗
Shure:  这白板拍一下拍
Shure: Take a picture of this whiteboard.
Jake: 拍完了然后擦
Jake: Take a picture and then erase it.
Jake: 再拍一下擦掉吧
Jake: Take another picture and erase it.
Katrina:  我刚拍了还有
Jake: 都可以调监控的
Jake:对就这么拍就行
Alice:淀粉
Shure: 哇真的好赛博啊看一眼我拍完你了
Shure:  哈哈哈
Jake:我记住你了
Alice: 大手套
Shure: 都可以
Katrina: 买点饮料
Jake:这啥呀酒
Shure: What's this? Alcohol?
Jake: 可以
Shure: 可以弄瓶伏特加
Shure: 因为伏特加调什么他就
Katrina: 这个冰我自己买模具啊
Katrina: 这是有冷冻还是只有冷藏
Shure: : 其实也可以直接外卖
Alice: 然后就把这两个固定就固定在第几层
Alice: Then just fix these two at whichever level.
Tasha: 然后呢用这个刀这样横着过去
Tasha: Then you use this knife to cut across horizontally.
Shure: : 可以有冰格这里面
Shure: 哎不是再往下一格
Shure: 啊那不是冰格
Shure: 看错了
Shure: 外卖买那个冰也没多贵
Shure: 一斤冰的话也就三四块钱
Jake: 挂上去
Tasha: 嗯糯米粉
Tasha: Yeah, glutinous rice flour.
Tasha: 两勺没了
Katrina: 哇好丰盛的材料
Lucia: 哎这个水是
Alice:没开的
Lucia: 那我可以开一瓶啊这瓶开过了
Jake: 对开过了
Lucia: 这瓶好像没开过
Lucia: This bottle seems unopened.
Lucia: 这瓶没开这瓶没开过
Lucia: This bottle is unopened, it's never been opened.
Jake: 要不贴个名字吧
Jake: 用那个小贴纸
Jake: 还在吗
Katrina: 这很好看
Shure: 是的
Jake: 那能记住吗
Alice: 过来有个人是一个撕掉
Alice: Someone comes over and tears it off.
Shure:  我今晚回宿舍然后回宿舍拿点
Katrina:  我把外面就撕下来
Katrina: I'll just tear off the outer part.
Katrina:  给他叠个花
Katrina: Fold a flower for him.
Jake: 就在这写个肩吧
Jake: Just write "shoulder" here.
Katrina: 你今晚回宿舍啊
Shure:  对
Jake: 哦你还要
Shure:  对我明天早上要答辩一下
Katrina: 你毕设这么早呢
Shure:  我们还有一个模拟答辩很奇怪
Lucia: 你们还有模拟答辩
Lucia: You still have a mock defense?
Shure:  哦你是软件工程的是吧
Katrina: 嗯
Shure: 好
Shure:  帮我改改代码吧到时候
Shure:  太爽了
Shure:  这出去搞杯咖啡喝在外面坐一坐晒太阳
Shure:  无敌了
Jake: 点外卖了吗
Jake: Did you order takeout?
Tasha:  还没吃午饭吗
Lucia: 对，现在几点了
Lucia: Yeah, what time is it now?
Jake: 一点不饿是吧
Jake: 我们再录40分钟就结束了这一部分
Jake: 然后40分钟能干吗呢
Jake:就是有40分钟外卖差不多能到吧
Shure: 可以
Jake: 单点一下然后准备一下下午买点啥应该是写一写
Jake: 拉倒了做东西
Jake: Forget it, let's make something.
Tasha: 就是在一楼做是吗
Tasha: Are we making it on the first floor?
Jake: 在一楼做
Tasha:  哦我就是问问
Jake: 在一楼做然后在这摆这就就当就是
Jake: 和甜点的那个台子放在也是这边是吧
Katrina: 咖啡是怎么做的，就是把那个粉倒进去
Shure:  不是就是它是滤纸的一个挂耳
Shure:  然后浇开水
Shure:  谢谢全
Shure: Thanks, everyone.
Tasha: 开放的那如果那一天上面是活动室
Tasha: If it's open, that day upstairs is the activity room.
Jake: 这边是会议室和厨房合理吧
Jake: This side is the meeting room and kitchen, right?
Shure:  我也带一点稍微带一点设备
Shure:  咖啡机就要很大的钱了
Lucia: 我还以为是我们戴的这个太像了
Shure: 是的
Shure: 混淆你们用的
Shure: AI中混入了一个傻子
Lucia: 只有一面
Jake:有背面背面是一个黑板
Jake: 对可以用粉笔写啊
Jake: Yeah, you can write with chalk.
Lucia: 对这个是这备用的一套是吗
Lucia: So this is the spare set, right?
Tasha: 我靠啊小心手
Tasha: Wow, be careful with your hand.
Jake: 咖啡整很好了是吧
Jake: The coffee turned out well, right?
Shure: 咖啡好像没有那么多
Jake: 哦哦
Shure: 而且只只能手冲
Jake: 哈哈哈一小杯就是one short
Shure:  咖啡也按烧腾喝是吧
Shure: You drink coffee boiled, right?
Jake:对对对
Shure:  直接烧腾浓缩
Shure: Directly boil it, make it strong.
Lucia: 我刚开始点真不会点点的short浓缩上来给我惊呆了
Shure: 好我们现在开始中午饭
Jake:午饭点外卖
Jake:外卖点什么呢
Jake: 看一看
Shure: 吃的点什么
Jake: 美团外卖
Shure:  美团外卖送啥都快
Alice:嗯垫子对要不然它会跑
Lucia: 哦OK好
Tasha: 他是用来干嘛的
Alice: 做他的lunch
Jake:打空气呢
Shure:  你阴湿
Jake:要不
Katrina: 我记一下我要买啥
Jake:报个菜名
Shure: 我请您吃
Shure: 我请大家吃
Shure: 何帆不认识饭
Shure: 牛肉饭加锅炉小锅牛肉
Shure: 吉野家肯德基宅基送聚德
Shure: 上北京烤鸭
Shure: 老街春饼
Shure: 南城香饭香串香馄饨香
Shure: 小栋酿猪脚饭
Shure: 酱骨饭汉堡王
Shure: 本味龙江猪脚饭
Shure: 人民公社大食堂神话烤鱼
Shure: 便益坊烤鸭
Shure: 河间驴肉火烧
Shure: 河骨烧日料寿司
Shure: 田老师红烧肉
Shure: 张记京味卤煮
Shure:  哈哈哈行了
Shure:  他们肯定一个都没记住
Jake:自己都没记住
Lucia: 我就听到一个KFC
Jake:好那就KFC吧怎么样
Lucia: 我只是只记得这个
Lucia:  因为太快了
Jake:可以啊
Shure: 还有汉堡王啊
Jake: 就KFC给外国人一些小震撼好吧
Lucia: 我我没有忌口大家吃什么都行
Katrina: 我想吃那奥尔良
Jake: 好那就
Shure: KFC
Jake: KFC
Shure: 全家桶
Jake:呃有些新品 热辣腹肌全是肉
Jake: 尊享无敌
Jake: Supreme enjoyment.
Alice: 用之前记得刷一遍
Shure: 披萨
Jake: 下面全是肉的披萨
Jake: The pizza is all meat.
Shure: 这是肯德基吗
Jake: 炸鸡炸鸡为对
Jake: 炸鸡是面皮的
Jake: The fried chicken has a crust.
Jake: 这个披萨
Jake: This pizza.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 炸火鸡是
Lucia: 这样我就可以自由活动
Lucia: That way I can move freely.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: 反正这里面垫应该还够
Lucia: Anyway, there should be enough padding inside.
Tasha: 这个放烤箱里
Tasha: Put this in the oven.
Jake: 这烤箱是不是有点歪Katrina: 这个也是放这里面吗
Jake: Is this oven a bit crooked? Katrina: Does this go in here too?
Katrina:  放这里面吗
Katrina: Does it go in here?
Alice:你那其实把它放上面也可以
Jake:好的
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh.
Lucia: 需要把要洗的东西单独挑出来一下吗
Lucia: Do we need to separate the things to be washed?
Jake: 好啊啊你们
Jake: Okay, you all...
Jake:那这个先不给路亚选
Jake: 哦这个底下哈哈哈
Jake: Oh, this bottom part, hahaha.
Tasha: 啊什么
Tasha: Huh, what?
Jake: 路亚一般不会第一个选是吧
Jake: Luya usually won't pick first, right?
Lucia:  哦对我一般都follow
Lucia: 就是大家选过的选项
Lucia: Just options everyone has picked.
Lucia: 就是点菜的时候
Jake:那个眼镜把那边头发对对
Jake: 先点吧要不
Jake: Let's order first then.
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: Oh dear
Tasha: 护护住眼镜
Lucia: 这个是不是也要拆一下
Lucia: Should we also take this apart?
Lucia: 就是撒糖霜的那个是吧
Lucia: It's the one with the powdered sugar, right?
Shure:  老板你你吃鸡堡
Shure: Boss, are you eating a chicken burger?
Shure:  吃牛堡哎
Shure: Or a beef burger?
Jake: 我能吃那个披萨吗
Jake: Can I have that pizza?
Shure:  可以
Lucia: 这有垃圾桶
Shure:  有人吃鸡堡吗
Shure: Anyone want a chicken burger?
Shure:  我想吃奥尔良考
Tasha: 好不想吃堡
Jake: 好那你可以吃
Shure: 哦不是奥尔良
Jake: 那你想吃什么
Jake: What do you want to eat?
Shure: 那行咱俩拼这个
Tasha: 不是不是我不想吃汉堡
Tasha: No, no, I just don't want a burger.
Tasha: 哦哦哦鸡肉卷
Tasha: Oh, oh, chicken wrap.
Jake: 要帮你吗
Jake: Need help?
Shure:  一个奥尔良
Shure: One Orleans.
Shure:  然后一个
Shure: And then one...
Jake:好好你帮我推进去
Jake: 我把这个弄起来好，我帮你扶着
Jake: I'll lift this up, okay, I'll hold it for you.
Shure:  好OK
Shure: Alright, OK.
Lucia: 这个袋子要拆掉吗
Lucia: Should we take this bag apart?
Tasha: 都要拆的
Tasha: Everything needs to be taken apart.
Jake:走走一波
Tasha: 呃我先把线扯上
Jake:好的
Jake:好的把线洗一洗
Lucia: 怎么回事我就把它系一下好了
Lucia: What's going on? I'll just tie it up.
Lucia: 要不然老拖地
Lucia: Otherwise, it'll keep dragging on the floor.
Tasha: 这其实还可以烤烤鸡来着
Tasha: Actually, you could roast some chicken with this.
Jake: 妙妙
Jake:  .
Lucia: 裱花嘴一会再拆吧
Lucia: Let's leave the piping bag for later.
Lucia: 别散的不知道到哪去
Lucia: Otherwise, it might get scattered.
Tasha: 这线插哪
Tasha: Where do I plug in this cord?
Tasha: 这这些都是材
Tasha: These are all ingredients.
Tasha: 食材就行啊
Tasha: Just the ingredients are fine.
Tasha: 把粉的放一起
Tasha: Put the powders together.
Tasha: 食材放一起
Tasha: Put the ingredients together.
Tasha: OK OK
Tasha: OK, OK.
Tasha:  好
Lucia: 这些也都要拆掉了是吧对
Lucia: So all of these need to be taken apart, right?
Lucia: 这都是粉
Lucia: This is all powder.
Tasha: 粉放到哪里呢
Tasha: Where should we put the powder?
Tasha: 粉就放这吧
Tasha: Let's just put it here.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 这些颗都给他
Lucia: Give him all these pieces.
Lucia: 塞一块上
Lucia: Stuff a piece on top.
Jake: 点完了
Jake: Finished ordering.
Jake: 点了几个
Jake: How many did you order?
Shure:  点了个双人餐
Shure: Ordered a meal for two.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure:  对那是我
Shure: Yeah, that was me.
Shure:  我点了一个双人餐
Shure: I ordered a meal for two.
Jake: 你一个人点了个双人餐
Jake: You ordered a meal for two by yourself?
Jake: 不是我我和那个
Jake: No, I mean with...
Shure:  雨轩对
Shure: Yuxuan, yeah.
Jake: 好是什么呢
Jake: 电池呢是电池啊啊
Tasha: 电池
Tasha: 巧克力搁这会不会化呀
Tasha: Will the chocolate melt if we put it here?
Shure:  有时候我忘通知的时候
Shure:  辛苦你帮我通知一下
Jake: 找着电池了是吧
Jake: Found the batteries, right?
Tasha: 因为这个电池是我带来的
Jake:哦
Lucia: 这个里面本来就有放东西
Lucia: 应该可以放些奶油什么的
Tasha: 还有套餐吗哈哈
Tasha: Are there still more meal sets? Haha.
Jake: 搜一搜
Jake: Search for it.
Jake: 没有哎有是是这个吗
Jake: No, wait, is this it?
Tasha: 那这不就一个吗
Tasha: Isn't this just one?
Tasha: 那就没有了
Tasha: Then there's none left.
Tasha: 那好吧那
Jake:还是这个吧
Jake: 不用套餐好的单点一些喝的是吗
Jake: No need for a set, just order some drinks, right?
Tasha: 喝的不用了吧
Jake:好没了
Jake: 嗯还有吗
Jake: Hmm, anything else?
Jake: 没了别的呢
Jake: Nothing else?
Jake: 这些小东西
Jake: These small items.
Tasha: 那我跟着他们吃吧
Tasha: Then I'll just eat with them.
Tasha: 这也是会点套餐吧
Tasha: They might also order meal sets.
Lucia: 巧克力是不是有两包
Lucia: Are there two packs of chocolate?
Lucia: 都不是一个是可可粉一个是可可豆
Lucia: No, one is cocoa powder and the other is cocoa beans.
Alice: 哇都点好了吗
Alice: Wow, did everyone finish ordering?
Jake: 点了三个
Jake: Ordered three.
Tasha:  呵呵但是被阳光晒的话他会不会坏
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh.
Lucia: 那我们要不然就放在
Tasha: 粉类放在这边
Tasha: 粉类可以放在这里没关系这个地方不是很容易晒到
Tasha: The powders can stay here, it's not very sunny in this spot.
Lucia: 粉类巧克力我都搁那个那里边
Lucia: I'll put the powdered chocolate in there.
Tasha: 巧克力给我吧
Tasha: Give me the chocolate.
Tasha: 巧克力可以放冰箱
Tasha: The chocolate can go in the fridge.
Jake: 给你一个
Jake: Here, have one.
Lucia: 这个是放在外面还是要放到冰箱去
Lucia: Should this be kept outside or in the fridge?
Jake: 你要套餐吗还是单点
Tasha: 这个放常温就行
Jake: 你要喝的吗
Jake: Do you want a drink?
Alice: 我不要
Tasha: 咖啡酒放冰箱
Lucia: 好的
Tasha: 要不这也放冰箱吧
Tasha: Or we could put this in the fridge too.
Tasha: 没地方放
Tasha: No space left.
Lucia: 行反正冰箱里东西少空间多
Tasha: 这个硅油纸啊小心谁把它放进去的
Tasha: Be careful with this parchment paper, who put it in here?
Tasha: 这个稍微往边上挪一点好
Tasha: Just move it a bit to the side, okay.
Jake: 来吧到你了
Jake: Alright, your turn.
Lucia: 让我看看大家都点了什么
Lucia: Let me see what everyone ordered.
Shure:  怎么选一堆然后全擦了呢
Shure: Why select a bunch and then erase it all?
Lucia: 一般来说
Lucia: Generally,
Lucia: 榴榴莲味的东西都有一点奇奇怪怪的
Lucia: Durian-flavored stuff always tastes a bit strange.
Katrina:  嗯就是一般我想吃就买这个
Lucia: Yeah, I usually buy this when I want to eat something weird.
Shure:  我呢还有一大瓶伏特加
Shure: I have a big bottle of vodka.
Katrina: 那行了那不用买伏特加了
Shure:  对你随便买一种基酒
Katrina: 那就买个朗姆我不太懂啊朗姆好像比较百搭
Shure:  对朗姆和伏特加都比较百搭
Shure:  伏特加就是它
Shure:  你对啥都基本上喝不出它本来
Shure: You can't really taste the original flavor.
Shure:  那个味但是桌子上没啥味
Shure: But there's no smell on the table.
Tasha: 那那要不把这这个给挪开
Tasha: How about we move this thing?
Shure: 就是小甜水
Shure:  这是什么呀
Shure: What is this?
Shure:  小甜水咣倒了
Jake: 这就是J人吗
Katrina: 是必要要把采购计划
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake: 我们有几个J人
Shure:  我是p
Jake:路亚是J人p人
Lucia: p人
Shure:  天啊
Shure: Oh my God.
Lucia: 万不得已
Jake:叉叉
Jake: 是j还是p人我是p人
Jake: Is it J or P people? I am P people.
Alice:我是p人
Jake: j人你觉得很j了
Jake: You think it's very J.
Alice: 我是p
Jake: VIP 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 唯一的
Katrina: 唯一的j人吗
Jake: 站着吧完了
Jake: Stand here, done.
Jake: 哈哈哈这个地方
Jake: Haha, this place.
Shure: 黑板就是你的了
Jake: 给你一个
Jake: Here you go.
Jake: 划一个区哈哈
Jake: Draw a zone, haha.
Jake: 哈哈这一区
Lucia: 把J人围起来观察
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 给你围个栅栏
Katrina: 围栅栏
Jake: 看到这个是不是很不爽
Jake: Does this make you feel annoyed?
Jake: 这些东西都要把它干掉
Jake: All this stuff needs to be taken out.
Shure: 好一会我们睡午觉就交给你了
Tasha: 这个也是搁这吧
Tasha: Let's put it here too.
Tasha: 我感觉这个没这个好使
Tasha: I feel this one is not as useful.
Alice: 那就给他搁这吧
Alice: Then let's leave it here.
Jake: 嗯行
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Jake: 这个能晒吗
Jake: Can this be dried?
Jake: 这些东西
Jake: These things.
Tasha: 可以没事粉没事
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Shure: 不都阴暗避光保存吗
Jake: Yes, the powder can be dried, it's not dark.
Jake:我看一下
Jake: 还有点
Jake: There's still a bit.
Tasha: 玉米油
Shure: 也有电
Jake:也有电
Jake: 行
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 哎你放那挡着有啥用
Jake: 你拿那些就搁这乱走的P人
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure:  我们在我们在观摩J人哈哈哈
Shure: We're just observing the street park, hahaha.
Lucia: 哎肯德基现在居然还有牛肉汉堡了
Lucia: Hey, KFC has beef burgers now.
Shure:  他俩应该配料都差不多
Shure: They probably have similar ingredients.
Katrina: 随心配一个
Shure:  对随心配就行
Shure:  对你这这些东西我都拿伏特加兑过
Shure: Yeah, I've mixed all these things with vodka before.
Shure:  都基本是一个味
Shure: They basically taste the same.
Jake: 我先把这个填起来
Jake: I'll fill this up first.
Shure:  哎呀哎哎呀哎呀
Shure: Oh my, oh my.
Jake: 真是多才多艺这是
Jake: So talented, this is.
Lucia:  这是怎么发出的声音
Shure: 12个现在
Shure:  差不多就行
Shure: That's about right.
Jake: 环保环保
Jake: Eco-friendly, eco-friendly.
Shure:  啊环保不能啊那那不行
Shure:  纸杯也就不行了
Shure: Paper cups won't work either.
Lucia: 我好了好的
Jake:好的
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Shure:  差不多
Shure: Pretty much.
Shure:  杯子就再说
Shure: Let's talk about the cups later.
Shure:  先不用买了
Shure: No need to buy them now.
Jake: 我们点了
Shure: 点吧
Shure:  觉得差不多
Shure: I think it's enough.
Jake: 我们总共三个
Jake: We have a total of three.
Jake: 可乐也行吧
Jake: Cola is fine, right?
Shure:  好像是我除了可乐
Shure: Seems like, apart from cola.
Shure:  我一会要coffee
Shure: I need coffee later.
Shure:  coffee没有coffee会死的
Shure: Without coffee, I'll die.
Jake: 我们要哎
Jake: We need, hey.
Jake: 肯德基是不是不用餐具点俩吧
Jake: Does KFC need utensils? Order two.
Lucia: 呃咱们早上有剩下的餐具
Lucia: Uh, we have leftover utensils from the morning.
Jake:哦那就点3个
Jake: 因为剩下的三个是吧
Jake: 啊什么东西
Jake: Ah, what is it?
Lucia: 哎不记得剩下几个啊
Lucia: Ugh, I can't remember how many are left.
Alice: 餐具哦哎等一下
Alice: The cutlery... oh, wait a second.
Alice: 动作太大
Alice: That was too much.
Jake: 搞定点两个
Shure:  ok
Jake: 大家等饭吃吧
Lucia: 我们我们要调几种酒啊
Lucia: So, how many types of drinks are we mixing?
Shure:  能调啥
Lucia: 基酒的话
Lucia: 威士忌和龙舌兰也可以考虑一下
Lucia: We could consider whiskey and tequila too.
Shure:  没事我明天
Lucia: 我投龙舌兰日出一票
Katrina: 你有这个那就买一瓶加一瓶龙舌兰
Shure:  我明天回宿舍看看有什么拿点
Shure: I'll check the dorm tomorrow to see what we have and grab some.
Katrina: 我们应该是会有多次采购吧
Jake: 对是的
Jake: Yeah, that's right.
Lucia: 如果买了朗姆的话不买龙舌兰也行
Lucia: 我觉得风味还是有一点相似之处的
Lucia: I think their flavors are somewhat similar.
Jake: 大概去个两次吧应该
Jake: We'll probably need to go twice.
Jake: 多的话就只能靠剧组带了
Jake: If there's more, we'll have to rely on the crew to bring it.
Tasha: 剧组今天怎么不来
Tasha: Why isn't the crew here today?
Jake: 剧组上课去了啊哈哈
Jake: The crew went to class, haha.
Jake: 剧组很忙
Jake: The crew is busy.
Jake: 兼组剧组兼职剧组
Jake: The crew is doing part-time work.
Lucia: 那个我只是清水冲就行朗姆的话
Shure: 不这不止是活动
Shure:  也是我们每天晚上的精神支柱好吗
Lucia: 呃如果如果我买了柳橙汁的话
Shure: Uh, if I buy orange juice...
Lucia: 也可以用气泡酒
Lucia: We can also use sparkling wine.
Lucia: 就是mimosa好会也是果汁
Lucia: Mimosa would work too, it's also juice.
Lucia: 果汁味浓一些然后酒精度低一点过水
Lucia: It has a stronger juice flavor and lower alcohol content.
Lucia: 嗯对还有这些
Jake: Hmm, yeah, and these.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: Then...
Lucia: 因为我不太确定大家喜欢喝什么样的
Lucia: Because I'm not sure what everyone likes to drink.
Lucia: 我感觉果偏果味的大家应该都能接受
Lucia: I feel like everyone should be okay with fruity flavors.
Lucia: 嗯全是这个要怎么冲就是喝着玩吗
Lucia: Yeah, how do we mix this, just for fun?
Shure: 就是这种接受度都蛮高的小甜水
Lucia: 我们我们好像还有果粒橙是吧
Lucia: We still have some orange juice with pulp, right?
Lucia: 那好像不买橙汁也行
Katrina: 那要买椰汁吗
Lucia: 椰汁要不先可以加入一下清单
Lucia: Let's add coconut water to the list first.
Lucia: 然后一会大家考虑一下
Lucia: Then everyone can think about it later.
Shure:  哎呦不好意思
Shure: Oh, sorry about that.
Lucia: 呃我看一下椰林飘香怎么调来着
Lucia: Uh, let me check how to make the Pina Colada.
Shure: 万能的就拿着就行
Shure:  啊西柚味那个是容器
Shure: Ah, the grapefruit flavor is for the container.
Katrina: 西柚味什么东西
Shure:  这些喝不了
Shure: We can't drink these.
Shure:  就当随时的饮料用
Shure: Just use them as drinks for any time.
Alice: 需要洗吗
Alice: Do we need to wash it?
Tasha: 他说他洗啊洗
Tasha: He said he'll wash it, yeah.
Jake: 哈哈对对对
Jake: Haha, yeah, exactly.
Tasha: 休息一下
Tasha: Take a break.
Tasha: 你已经整理过很多东西了
Tasha: You've already organized a lot of stuff.
Alice:没关系是的
Jake: 是的休息一下
Shure: 休息一下
Jake: 打散了再拼一次
Jake: 哎啊拼命图
Jake: Ah, take a break from working hard.
Jake: 打散了再拼一次
Shure: 为什么多出来一个螺丝。
Jake: 休息一下
Jake: Take a break.
Shure: 我刚从兜里面掏出来一个。
Shure:  装完所有零件
Shure: After assembling all the parts.
Shure: 发现多出来一颗螺丝我之前装电脑就是
Shure: 我把那个笔记本拆了清灰然后全拆完
Shure:  最后都装回去
Shure: I put everything back together.
Shure:  发现多了两个螺丝
Jake: 要不就是没用的东西都给扔出去
Jake: Or just throw away the useless stuff.
Jake: 对就是这个
Jake: Yeah, that's it.
Jake: 然后他们采购的东西补一补
Jake: Then restock the things they bought.
Lucia: 对但是其实也不一定非要放这么多
Lucia: Yeah, but actually, we don't necessarily need to add so much.
Lucia: 就是朗姆酒加椰汁兑
Lucia: Just mix rum with coconut milk.
Lucia: 然后我个人觉得可能就菠萝汁
Lucia: And personally, I think maybe pineapple juice.
Lucia: 换成别的果汁也行
Lucia: You can replace it with other fruit juices.
Lucia: 因为咱也不需要调的那么正经嘛对吧
Lucia: Because we don't need to be that serious about mixing, right?
Lucia: 所以可以考虑一下
Lucia: So, consider that.
Lucia: 对我
Lucia: Yeah, I...
Lucia: 其实我觉得只要有可乐
Lucia: Actually, I think as long as there's cola.
Lucia: 跟任何东西都可以兑一起是的
Lucia: You can mix it with anything, really.
Tasha: 嗨你做甜品的时候可以帮你
Tasha: Hey, when you're making desserts, I can help you.
Tasha: 好啊是一个超级的
Tasha: Okay, it's a super...
Jake: 我们还有20分钟就结束了这一段
Jake: We have 20 minutes left to finish this part.
Jake: 然后20分钟之内
Jake: And within 20 minutes...
Jake: 呃就就把这些事情都给截掉
Jake: Uh, we should cut out all these things.
Jake: 然后是一个完整的片段
Jake: Then it will be a complete segment.
Jake:好吧
Shure:  好那我们就这个片段
Shure:  就是5个P人观察一个J人的计划
Shure:  对就是我们现在就收尾
Shure: Yes, we’re wrapping it up now.
Jake: 就不要开心的事情了就把这个给收掉
Jake: No more fun stuff, just wrap this up.
Jake: 稳
Lucia:  那我们就大家围在一起观察一下吧
Katrina: 差不多然后还要什么我们还要买一些
Tasha: 帮我写一下
Tasha: Write it down for me.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 鸡蛋
Jake: 你们要不坐啊
Shure:  鸡蛋每天早上咱们可以煮着吃
Lucia: 每天早上煮
Tasha: 嗯白糖是不是也没有
Lucia: Hmm, is there no white sugar either?
Alice: 有糖粉但是没白糖
Alice: We have powdered sugar but no white sugar.
Tasha: 可是我觉得白糖其实呃好一些
Katrina: 要白糖是吗
Tasha: 嗯买吧白糖还有盐也需要一小包
Tasha: Hmm, let’s buy some white sugar, and we also need a small packet of salt.
Tasha: 你可以写在一起
Tasha: You can write it together.
Katrina: 要不要一次性餐具
Tasha: 盐一次性餐具打算在
Shure: 不环保
Tasha:  网上买
Katrina: 不环保他们拿啥吃呢
Shure:  手抓哈哈哈
Shure: Eat with our hands, haha.
Shure:  手抓烤出来直接拿那个夹子啪放手上
Shure: Grab the roasted food directly with tongs and put it on your hand.
Katrina: 白糖盐
Tasha: 嗯等一下我从第一个开始看牛奶
Tasha: Hmm, let me check the milk first.
Shure: 这还有个雪克锅呢
Jake: 嗯
Shure:  这个这可以
Shure:  晚上整一个寿喜锅吃
Shure: Let’s have sukiyaki for dinner.
Alice: 鸡蛋的
Alice: 用无菌蛋吧
Alice: Use sterile eggs.
Tasha: 对用无菌蛋也更好一些了
Tasha: Yeah, sterile eggs are better.
Shure:  那还可以生吃
Shure: Then we can eat them raw.
Shure:  每天早上
Shure: Every morning.
Tasha: 呃鸡蛋汤
Tasha: Uh, egg soup.
Tasha: 嗯也可以买点装饰薄荷什么
Tasha: Hmm, we can also buy some mint for decoration.
Tasha: 调酒是不是也可以用
Tasha: Can it be used for cocktails too?
Tasha: 薄荷百里香什么都可以
Tasha: Mint, thyme, anything is fine.
Tasha: 保鲜膜这有吗没有
Jake:没有
Jake: 呃我没看到应该没有吧
Jake: Uh, I didn't see it, should be no.
Jake: 路亚看过没有对吧
Jake: Have you seen Lure before, right?
Lucia: 没有应该是没有
Lucia: No, I don't think so.
Lucia: 应该没有
Lucia: Shouldn't be.
Lucia: 好的他们这餐具只有
Lucia: Okay, they only have these utensils.
Lucia: 比如说那个锅碗瓢盆这些
Lucia: Like pots, pans, those kinds of things.
Tasha: 淡奶油
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 鸡蛋淀粉嗯盐盐液小糖牛奶淡奶油
Tasha: Eggs, starch, hmm, salt, liquid salt, a bit of sugar, milk, whipping cream.
Tasha: 如果有一小包的奶粉也可以带一包
Tasha: If there's a small pack of milk powder, you can bring one.
Shure: 奶粉
Tasha:一包奶粉
Tasha: 咖啡粉咖啡粉手冲吧
Tasha: Coffee powder, coffee powder for hand brewing.
Shure:  跟那个不一样吧
Shure: Isn't that different?
Shure:  你要的是什么咖啡粉
Tasha: 我就要一包咖啡粉
Katrina: 做提拉米苏吗
Tasha: 啊对
Lucia: 做有用的咖啡粉也可以吗
Tasha: 对
Tasha: 啊你们不磨吗
Tasha: Ah, you guys don't grind it?
Shure:  啊
Katrina: 我也想买点咖啡茶喝万一嘛
Jake: 哎我我还带了一个咖鸭
Jake: Hey, I also brought a coffee duck.
Jake: 就是新加坡的一个很很奇怪的调料
Jake: It's a very strange seasoning from Singapore.
Tasha: 也可以再写蛋挞皮
Alice: 这个纸箱还要吗
Alice: Do we still need this cardboard box?
Lucia: 这纸箱要不要留一下
Lucia: Should we keep this box?
Lucia: 假如我们
Jake: 留着留着
Lucia: 假如我们要做一些什么纸箱狗之类的
Lucia: 可以摆在门口
Lucia: 然后就当迎宾
Lucia: And be used as a welcoming.
Alice: 那能把纸箱都留着
Alice: Then let's keep all the boxes.
Jake: 对纸箱留着吧
Jake: Yeah, keep the boxes.
Jake: 放在外面那种
Jake: Put them outside.
Lucia: 那种特别软特别薄的就不需要了
Lucia: 或者说就是破破损面积很大那种家咖啡馆的
Lucia: Or the ones with large damaged areas like in the café.
Tasha: 不用咖啡房
Tasha: No need for the coffee room.
Tasha: 没事我来吧
Tasha: It's okay, I'll do it.
Alice: 就搁这吧
Alice: Just leave it here.
Shure:  我明天我明天
Shure: 补给一波装备好吧
Shure:  我今天回家啊我回宿舍补给一波
Tasha: 然后再买草莓
Tasha: And then buy some strawberries.
Shure:  想想啊有音箱话筒然后咖啡酒
Lucia: 草莓能放几天啊
Lucia: How long can strawberries last?
Tasha: 草莓能放
Tasha: Strawberries can last...
Tasha: 放冰箱的话两三天吧
Tasha: If you put them in the fridge, about two or three days.
Shure:  3天吧
Shure: About 3 days.
Jake: 3天我们不会吃吗
Jake: Won't we eat them in 3 days?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 那就大概过上三四天左右再去
Lucia: So maybe we should go buy more in about three or four days.
Lucia: 买一次对
Lucia: Right.
Tasha: 那就没有了
Tasha: Then there won't be any left.
Lucia: 外援
Lucia: Backup.
Shure:  不咖啡豆我没了
Shure: No, I'm out of coffee beans.
Shure:  我需要买
Shure: I need to buy some.
Shure:  趁机补给一波对
Shure:  咖啡的一些东西对
Shure: And some other coffee stuff.
Shure:  嗯以及泡咖啡的
Shure: Hmm, and make some coffee.
Lucia: 这个手套要不
Lucia: Should we put this glove here?
Lucia: 放这好了
Lucia: Let's just leave it here.
Jake: 对我们这边只有一个j
Jake: Yeah, we only have one "J" here.
Jake: 然后没有s
Jake: And no "S".
Lucia: 竟然没有s
Lucia: No "S", really?
Jake:没有s
Jake: 是我们总共30多个报名的人里边
Jake: Out of the 30-something people who signed up,
Jake: 就三个要
Jake: only three wanted
Jake: 要这两个s
Jake: those two "S".
Tasha: 嗯s是啥
Alice: s觉得这种事没有意义
Alice: "S" thinks this kind of thing is meaningless.
Lucia: 有可能s比较
Lucia: Maybe "S" is more...
Jake: s是是啥好像是
Jake: "S" is like, um...
Jake: 什么感性和直觉和感觉
Jake: something emotional, intuitive, and sensory.
Lucia: 直觉和感觉
Lucia: Intuitive and sensory.
Jake: 对实感
Jake: Yeah, real feelings.
Jake: 就这个实在是没法打官司
Jake: This is really impossible to argue.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Lucia: 原来如此
Lucia: 那所以是p人更多还是j人更多
Lucia: So are there more "P" people or "J" people?
Lucia: 按照按照就是最终的结果来说的话
Lucia: According to the final results,
Lucia: 应该报名的时候也是p人多
Lucia: there should have been more "P" people who signed up.
Jake:对对对压倒性的
Jake: 对p人多对对对
Lucia: 为什么p人多
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Lucia: 哎这个可这个可以扔了吗
Lucia: Hey, can we throw this away?
Lucia: 这里面还有一个
Lucia: There's one more in here.
Lucia: 这个也
Lucia: This one too.
Shure: 美纹纸是什么
Katrina: 就是我姐跟我说贴墙上就无痕的那个
Lucia: 那这个放在跟那些放一起吧
Lucia: Let's put this one with the others.
Lucia: 然后这个可以扔了对吧
Lucia: And we can throw this one away, right?
Lucia: 对那就扔掉了
Lucia: Okay, let's throw it away then.
Jake: 就是第一波那个
Jake: It's from the first batch.
Jake: 呃复活节的那一次
Jake: Uh, from the Easter event.
Jake: 呃那报名的里边只有三个
Jake: Uh, there were only three people who signed up.
Jake: 只有三种
Jake: Only three types.
Jake: 只有只有三种
Jake: Only, only three types.
Jake: 这个NBTI只有三种
Jake: This NBTI only has three types.
Lucia: 只有三种
Jake: 对总共十几个人总共我们把那个把这个喝了吧
Jake: Yes, out of a dozen people total, let's drink this.
Shure:  我们把那个美汁源喝了吧
Lucia: 幸好最后我没有复活
Lucia: Thankfully, I didn't come back.
Lucia:节举办因为突然
Lucia: Because suddenly
Lucia: 就是就是突然之间
Lucia: Just suddenly
Lucia: 我就是那一周事情还蛮多的
Lucia: I had a lot going on that week.
Lucia: 然后我一直忙到就是来这之前的一周
Lucia: And I was busy up until the week before coming here.
Shure:  哎这有一个那个咖啡利口酒
Lucia: 很荣幸认识大家
Lucia: It's an honor to meet you all.
Alice: 对要做那啥的啊
Alice: Right, we need to do that thing.
Alice:哈哈这个不能动他
Tasha: 这还可以煮火锅哎
Tasha: We can even use this for hot pot.
Alice: 把这个也打了吧
Alice: Let's blend this too.
Jake: 搞一天火锅
Jake: Make hot pot for a day.
Jake: 可以啊
Jake: Sure.
Lucia: 哎对火锅也比较方便
Lucia: Yeah, hot pot is pretty convenient.
Lucia: 买一些简单的食材
Lucia: Just buy some simple ingredients.
Lucia: 火锅底料直接煮就好了
Lucia: Use the hot pot base and cook.
Alice:丸子羊肉片对
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Sounds good.
Lucia: 我们自己做饭的环节
Lucia: For our cooking session,
Lucia: 不如就做火锅
Lucia: Let's just make hot pot.
Alice: 这是我们买的
Alice: We bought this.
Jake: 放进去可以
Jake: Put it in, that's fine.
Shure:  他这冰箱全是空的
Shure: His fridge is completely empty.